the drug war and cyber I would say are
two of the most miss prosecuted men
misunderstood and contentious areas of
law that we face in America today and
Ross is smack in the middle of those two
I'm Zach why smaller for reason TV we're
here at the silent movie theater in Los
Angeles for a screening of Deep Web a
new documentary by director and producer
Alex winter Alex thanks for talking to
us thank you
Deep Web is about a kind of encrypted
version of the Internet that you need a
special browser to access and people use
crypto currencies to buy things that
maybe they're not supposed to buy but at
its heart it's a personal portrait of
Ross Ulbricht the creator of the
notorious online black market Silk Road
let's start there what is your
impression of Ross Ulbricht from what
you've been able to piece together
during the movie I don't have a concrete
impression of Ross the movie is really
about what I do and don't know and what
my impressions are in art which is in a
way he's whatever anybody decides to
impose upon this idea of who he is as
parents and his family members see him
as this very good-hearted peaceful
pacifistic brilliant young man that
they've known their whole lives with no
criminal tendencies and no even hostile
tendencies the libertarian community has
sort of embraced him because of his
libertarian politics as being somewhat
of a hero on the libertarian side the
crypto anarchists have said no he's
actually not a libertarian he goes
farther than the libertarians he's more
of a an anarchist he's more of a
revolutionary law enforcement the
government of course has branded him as
sort of this nefarious murderous Walter
White of the Internet age this corrupted
evil drug overlord so really there's a
very almost kaleidoscopic impression
that I have as to who Ross is it's
possible that some of those ideas are
wrong it's possible that some version of
all of them are right in a sort of
PostScript to the film Ross was
sentenced and in a shocking move the
judge actually went above and beyond
what the prosecutors were even asking
for and gave him a life sentence what's
your reaction to that
was the first time I think for myself
that I felt categorically that there had
been something unjust occurring no
matter what Ross was guilty of no matter
what he did or didn't do no matter what
aspect of what he had been charged with
he truly had done a life sentence
without parole is is shockingly extreme
secondarily the the bluntness by which
the judge communicated why she was
pronouncing this sentence what took
everyone really by surprise she gave a
very impassioned speech basically in
defense of the drug war and in defense
of the what she called the social fabric
that needed to be defended and which she
felt Ross and technologies like the
technologies that Ross was connected to
not even created but even tangentially
connected to disrupted the social fabric
of were dangerous and therefore she had
to make an example of him it's
interesting because you know you said
you hope this kind of kaleidoscopic view
of Ross and everyone sees their own
little sliver of what he is and
apparently that extends to federal
judges as well because she saw him as
some sort of symbol the one thing he did
that was the most dangerous to his own
future was to insert himself in the
crosshairs of the cyber criminal world
and law and the drug war and the drug
war and cyber I would say are two of the
most miss prosecuted men misunderstood
and contentious areas of law that we
face in America today and Ross is smack
in the middle of those two and I think
that had a lot to do with the severity
of his sentence so you're maintaining
kind of distance and a skepticism
towards what Ross did and didn't do and
one of the most controversial aspects of
him as a character in the media are
these allegations that he ordered
several hits against enemies of the Silk
Road people who were threatening to
unveil the anonymity that was the whole
point of the market what do you make of
those allegations it's really hard to
say there are two sort of prongs to
those
murder allegations there are there's the
diaries which were found on Ross's
computer which were not continuous
journals there were only a couple of
entries made and then suddenly
apparently in 13 when the most nefarious
activity was going on when Ross claims
he wasn't even involved in the Silk Road
he started journaling like crazy about
all these really heinous criminal acts
he believed those were fabric I think I
don't know all I know is that as a as a
documentarian I certainly do not feel it
is within my right knowing the power of
a documentary and a power of a movie and
if I put forward a theory it's taken as
tacit fact and I think that it's I think
frankly from a journalistic standpoint
as well it's extremely irresponsible to
fall hard on one side of the other of
allegations involving murder that have
not been charged much less proven you
know from a commercial filmmaking
standpoint it would have been great to
say sure this guy is you know Walter
White of the Internet I mean I probably
the movie would have probably made tens
of millions of dollars but it's
irresponsible stepping back from all
bricks a little bit and looking at the
broader Deep Web and the darknet and
making this film
have you come to view that wider project
a lot of people use the darknet for
privacy and anonymity the idea that
there is this thing called the deep red
that is 10 times larger than the visible
internet the syllabic criminals is
nonsense it's just a phosphate the Deep
Web is just as giant gobbledygook of
data and a tiny little fraction of that
is the darknet and there's a subset of
that where there's some criminal
activity going on but even that tiny
little fraction of the darknet mostly
privacy and anonymity yeah but the the
fear that people have of that subsection
people are afraid that it's inevitably
gonna be used to sell drugs and Firearms
and however you feel about that there's
other things that are even worse you
know child porn assassinations do you
does that kind of thing concern you do
you think that it's people should really
be afraid of that here's what concerns
me what concerns me is the
misunderstanding of and the
mythologizing of this space this the
darknet and tools like tor are just
tools they're nothing more criminal
activity occurs
everywhere human-beings congregate just
say that you are Pro Tour does not mean
that you're pro child abuse just to say
that being pro New York City does not
mean that I am Pro Street crime just
because they're a street crime in New
York City from my perspective it's
absurd
it's worse than absurd in that I think
there's an somewhat of an agenda behind
the demonizing mythologizing of these
technologies and I think that agenda is
to prevent average citizens from having
privacy and anonymity in the digital
space this is threatening on a number of
levels making a movie about anonymity
you brought some characters in front of
the camera that are naturally people
that do not want to go in front of the
camera they're cloaking themselves with
all this encryption was it difficult
with the process of getting them to talk
to you difficult and just if you can
take us behind the scenes a little bit
how did you manage to get these people
to talk to you well I've been involved
in that space for a long time for 20
years or so so I have a lot of
connections in that world all the core
architects the motive for the people who
got involved in the Silk Road they were
coming from the Occupy movement they
were they were you know vigorously anti
drug war they wanted to use technology
to change policy these were political
people interesting so because they were
political people and not just your
average drug dealer they wanted to talk
I've gotten a lot of communication from
people since the movie came out thanking
me for the film and saying this is
actually what it felt like to be in the
Silk Road as opposed to how it's been
represented in the media and it wasn't
about glorifying it it wasn't like I
tried to say this is a good thing it was
just because I showed that it was a
political engine first and foremost what
do you see with the future of the deep
web and the dark net and separately of
Ross Ulbricht well Ross is going to
appeal and I would like to see them win
an appeal is there a particular
particularly strong grounds for appeal
that you think might be the route yeah I
think that I think that the sentencing
being so harsh making an example of a
young man you're basically putting in
max for 50 or 60 years as you know
tantamount to torture so you know that's
what the Unabomber gets and then to your
second question you know the darknet I
did this movie on Napster which is all
about you know looking at peer-to-peer
file-sharing Moroz sort of birth of
global communities online and music
sharing and I would say Silk Road is
very similar Silk Road is really the
next big
Watershed technology in the history of
the evolution of online community rock
so many people together but it brought
them together anonymously it's a big
leap forward as you've seen in them in
the markets this is the beginning this
is not the end of anything the the
they're going to become decentralized
they're going to proliferate at an
enormous rate privacy is becoming a
booming business and the post Snowden
era so we're at the beginning of an era
of understanding our right as citizens
to privacy online and that is going to
grow it's not going to shrink Alex
winter thank you very much for talking
to us
the movie is deep web you can watch it
on epics it'll be available for download
on iTunes and all other VOD platforms at
the end of this summer for recent TV I'm
Zack Weissmuller